الان في اوكرانيا مصير النظام الدولي
العالمي
يتم
تقريره وانا مع الرئيس بايدن وشركاء
والحلفاء سنواصل بذل كل منستطيع حتى ينتصر
العالم الديمقراطي في هذه المعركه
التاريخيه
اوكرانيا
تتذكر التركيز والموقف الذي تبناه الرئيس
بايدن والشعب الامريكي واوكرانيا ستواصل
على اتصال مستمر مع رئيس الولايات المتحده
طيله هذه الحرب وهذه هي الزياره الاولى
طيله 15 عاما وهي اهم زياره في تاريخ
العلاقات بين اوكرانيا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذه زياره تاتي في اصعب الظروف
التي تمر بها اوكرانيا التي تدافع عن حريه
العالم
وهي تؤكد نتائج التي حققناها
وما يمكن ان نحققه من انجازات معا مع
الولايات المتحده
والعالم واوروبا واليوم
مباحثتنا كانت مثمره للغايه
وكانت مهمه
وحاسمه وقد اضحك ذلك تقليدا بين بلدين اود
ان اشكر واقدر رئيس بايدن وفريقه
والكونغرس والشعب الامريكي
واشكركم على اشكركم على هذا المستوى الذي
وصلت اليه العلاقات بين البلدين وخلال هذا
الاسبوع سوف نحيي مرورا عام على معركتنا
ضد روسيا
يجب ان نعزز تصميمنا
وزيارتي في ديسمبر وكذلك زياره السيد رئيس
الامريكي لاكياف
سوف
ينظر الى اليهما والى هذه الزياره على
انها دليل على عزمنا لتحرير اراضي اراضينا
والاوكرانيا
دائما
عبرت عن تقديرها
للعلاقات مع الولايات المتحده وكذلك عملت
على ارساء الاساس للتعاون في المجال
الدفاعي وكذلك
اود ان اشكر الرئيس بايدن على كل ما قدمه
من مساعدات عسكريه مثل
الذخائر والمعدات الاخرى التي قدمت الى
اوكرانيا
ادركها السيد الرئيس انه سيكون هناك
حزم عسكريه مهمه تقدم الى اوكرانيا وهذا
سيكون اشاره واضحه بان مساعي روسيا لن
تنجح ومعا سوف ندافع عن مواطنين
ومدننا ضد روسيا وهذا سوف يمنح زخما
لتحقيق النصر وقد اكدنا اليوم ان لدينا
وجهه نظر مشتركه
وكذلك
ننسخ للتصدي للدوله الارهابيه الروسيه
ونعمل على تعزيز
العقوبات ثنائي وفي اطار مجموعه السبع
ايضا نحن لدينا رؤيه مشتركه بشان محتوى
الكثير من اوجه
العلاقات
الدفاعيه او الامنيه بين بلدينا كما اننا
عازمون على احترام ميثاق الامم المتحده
والدفاع عن النظام العالمي الذي يستند على
القواعد وهذا مهم لكافه الدول التي يهمها
الامن العالمي نحن نريد استعاده العداله
وهذا امر مهم للغايه ايضا لكل اولئك الذين
تضرروا بالارهاب الروسي والحرب الروسيه
ويجب على روسيا ان تعود كافه لضاله تتسببت
بها ونشكر الرئيس الامريكي على دوره ودعمه
لاوكرانيا او لكافه المؤسسات الاوكرانيه
نحن نؤمن بانه لا بديل لاقامه محكمه خاصه
هذا هو موقف اوكرانيا وسوف ندعم هذا
الموقف نود من الولايات المتحده ان تشارك
في تنفيذ اتفاق سلام الذي نقدمه
لتعزيز الاستقرار العالمي وكذلك لتكون
هناك علاقات دوليه يمكن تنبؤ بها خلال هذا
الاسبوع مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
واكثر من 60 بلد اخر سوف تقدم هذه الدول
في نيويورك مسوده قرار لدعم السلامي في
اوكرانيا في الرابع والعشرين من فبراير
ونحن نرى ان مشروع
القرار هذا سيكون خطوه مهمه على الطريق
الصحيح
ونحن ايضا
نعمل على
فتحي
او توجيه نداء تقدير للرئيس بايدن ولقد
اجرينا محادثات
واولين اهتمام خاص
لحمايه الديمقراطيه في اوكرانيا واشكر
الرئيس بايدن على مساهمته لدعم الحريه
الديمقراطيه في العالم
سيتذكر الاوكرانيون ذلك واوكرانيا ممتنه
لكم السيد الرئيس